Want to
bring back our political experts
for more analysis
on the breaking news
we're following right now.
Ron DeSantis
officially publicly
launching his campaign
for president of the United States
on Twitter.
And Caitlyn, I understand
they got some problems over there.
What are you hearing?
Yeah, this was a concern
that some people had today
when they said
they were going to be announcing
this on Twitter spaces,
which is essentially this audio
only offer that Twitter has.
You could go
and listen to a conversation
to one as that's what,
David, tax fraud is in Disneyland,
what they're supposed to be doing.
But clearly, I'm
not sure if they anticipated
how many people would be listening
to this or trying to join in on this.
Obviously, you know,
quite a audience on this.
And there's a lot of glitches, Wolf,
that are delaying this.
It's still a difficulty
to even actually listen
to this conversation.
So even totally clear
if it's fully started.
They were trying to do so
a few moments ago
and start this conversation.
You heard Elon Musk briefly
speaking on this,
but it essentially kept
crashing and kept dropping.
And this is something that
was a potential to happen.
Obviously,
Twitter has not been running smoothly
as you've seen
how understaffed it's been.
And even the Biden campaign
has been mocking it already.
The President Biden
sending out a tweet
saying this link works.
It's a link to fundraise
for his campaign.
He's already ripping the dissent,
his campaign launch and
just how glitchy it is
doubling that off to the
to a smooth start.
And this is a concern, of course.
And this is what when you do have
those similar
traditional campaign announcement
announcements,
you don't have an issue like this.
But this is how the dissenters campaign
so far is getting started
where they're having
not a very controlled issue.
And Elon Musk keeps talking about
how many people are trying to listen.
Obviously, the expectation would be
that they knew
it'd be a widely
listened to
campaign launch
and clearly having a lot of issues
I don't even think
it's actually happening right now, Wolf.
It's very awkward.
But what I can say,
we're supposed
to start about 20 minutes or so ago.
It hasn't started yet.
Sara, you're a social media analyst.
You're an expert in this whole area.
Give us your analysis of what's going on.
This major glitch
unfolding right now for the
for the DeSantis campaign.
Yes, I was in that audio space.
And when I joined, Wolf,
there were about 667,000 people
that were trying to listen.
That's what
the audio space said at the time.
Now, to give you some context.
Twitter has held much bigger events.
When Elon did
his BBC interview through audio,
I think that got up to 3 million people.
But what I think
they probably didn't anticipate
was this many people coming in
at the exact same time
because they had announced
that this was going to happen at 6 p.m..
You can imagine
hundreds of thousands of nine over
a million people
trying to listen to this.
And the problem,
Wolf, is that
when you're to
have such a high frequency event
in any kind of technology,
it could be on social media.
I'm on my phone right now.
It can be on streaming
when you're watching sports.
It's that huge dilution of people
coming in at the same time
that often messes things up.
Now, the problem
that this is going to have
are the DeSantis campaign
and Caitlyn just mentioned
this is that
he's trying to send this message
that I can bypass the traditional media.
I can go direct to my listeners.
Well, when the first time
you try to do that
in launching your campaign,
it doesn't work.
And you're almost a half hour
late to the announcement.
It's a very bad look.
It's going to make him likely less,
you know, risk taking
when it comes to this type of thing
in the future.
You're absolutely right, Abby.
This is clearly not the rollout
that DeSantis and his campaign
we're looking for.
We're hoping for, is it?
No, it's not.
But I mean, I
think we have to be honest
that this outcome was pretty predictable.
I mean, especially given the troubles
that this platform, Twitter
has had in the past,
the challenge
with doing an event like this,
if you were Ron DeSantis
and you're
trying to present
an image of a competent campaign
that has its advance
work done,
that knows how to put together a smooth
running event,
which is a
kind of microcosm
of a smooth running campaign,
doing it in
this format
always introduced a huge amount of risk.
And what's happening
now is that instead of talking about
what Ron DeSantis is running on
and and how he's running,
what his campaign looks like,
people are going to be talking
about how this event went.
And there is such a thing
as negative attention.
And he's
right now
getting a lot of negative attention.
And that's probably going to continue.
And it's probably not going to be undone
by anything that is said later
tonight in a more traditional format.
First impressions matter
they matter a lot in politics.
And I think that he is learning
a really important lesson right now
that, you know,
if you're going to do something
unconventional,
you really have to have your ducks
in a row and understand
how this is working.
And as Sarah was saying,
there were about 600,000 people in this
in this event.
That's not actually that many people.
I when I checked a couple of minutes ago,
it was about 300,000.
So a lot of people are leaving.
Maybe they're being kicked out
because of technical glitches.
Those are not huge numbers.
It should be able to be handled
by a corporate, a competent corporation
and a competent campaign.
The fact that it's not is,
I think, very problematic on both. Right.
Very awkward for the DeSantis campaign.
Indeed.
And Jessica Dean, you're there in Miami.
What are you learning about
DeSantis, his next move
Well, we just heard him
that Twitter Spaces is now up,
and he just announced
that he is officially running
for president.
A source familiar had told me
he was going to stay there and speak
despite the glitches
that is indeed what has happened.
So we just heard from him.
At this point,
it's up and running
and people can hear it.
It is the conversation
between the governor and Elon Musk.
And again,
Wolf, the news here
is that he did just officially announce
that he is running for president.
But we're going to continue to monitor
this and listen in
and we'll bring you more as it happens.
David Chalian,
what do you make of this glitch
at the end?
I think it is fair to judge.
But what you've heard here
from my colleagues that
the DeSantis team set this up as,
hey, look at this cool thing
we're going to do in this
totally unconventional way.
And it didn't go smoothly.
And so that is certainly a fair critique.
I don't think it's going to be
a long lasting problem for his campaign.
It's already up and running.
He'll move on to other things.
We will start focusing a lot more,
as Alex suggested,
on his appeal to voters, his interaction
with voters, the policies
he's running on.
I don't think this will be
the definitional moment of the DeSantis
presidential campaign.
But it's certainly not any way
anybody on Team DeSantis
would have designed this.
You noted that
Joe Biden, the president,
and his team started mocking it.
Nikki Haley's team has already put out
a video
of their widely praised launch
from back in February.
She had a big event in South Carolina.
They rolled out
video of that praising their ability
to launch their campaign.
So it's something that I think
a lot of insiders
paying attention to
this will poke fun at.
I think at the end of the day,
I can't imagine
real Republican
primary voters
making their decision
based on on a technical glitch.
All right.
Jeff Zeleny, you're our political expert.
Give us the big picture right now.
What does all this mean?
Wolf, I think David is right.
I mean, the reality is this,
of course, is not a scripted rollout,
as Governor
DeSantis would have wanted it.
But we've always known the most important
day is tomorrow, not today.
There are many Republican voters
who are hungry for an alternative
to Donald Trump.
That's what this race is indeed
going to be about.
Perhaps this will be a metaphor.
We do not know.
But the biggest day is tomorrow.
And one of the things that is interesting
is the generational argument
and the generational change argument
that he is hoping to make. He has
he has three young children.
He's 44 years old,
about half the age of the president,
and almost the same as Donald Trump.
So he is going to make that argument
to conservatives out there.
So I think we will quickly
forget about this.
Elon Musk a Twitter situation.
It's a judgment call perhaps,
and perhaps
they won't do that in the future.
But his campaigning going forward here,
is he able to sort of
live up to the expected options
that Republican donors have
and Republican voters and activists have?
That is a big open question here.
Donald Trump has had the
the luxury of running for president
a couple of times before.
That is a huge advantage here.
But one thing that the does
and his campaign
is going to be relying on that's
slightly different
than previous
campaigns is a large
super PAC called Never Back Down.
They're essentially going to outsource
much of their work on the campaign.
That is also going to raise
some questions here about the control
that Governor DeSantis
will have over all of this.
He's known for some even supporters
and admirers
believe he's a control freak.
So how he is able to sort of run
as a as a
candidate while
there is this super PAC out there
that is essentially
knocking on doors
and they have
these very large goals of hiring
thousands of people
in early voting states.
How he's able to manage
all that will be sort of
well set the stage for the success
of this candidacy.
But, Wolf,
the first presidential debate
is about three months or so from now.
So he does not have much time
to get up to speed here.
Yes, he has executive experience
in Florida,
signed a bunch of laws,
but his campaign begins
a whole new phase in his young
political life again. 44 years old.
So that is a generational change
and a challenge for him as well.
I suspect the DeSantis campaign,
DeSantis himself,
they regret
the fact
they didn't do a more traditional launch,
a real speech,
which all the cable networks
presumably would have been taking live.
Millions of people
might have been watching.
Instead, they've got this
this Twitter glitch that's going on.
Right.